los grupos políticos de la izquierda
española parece que podrán Mostrar
unidad de Cara a las elecciones
anticipadas del 23 de Julio una unidad
que se define en la formación sumar
creada en abril por la ministra de
trabajo y vicepresidenta Segunda del
gobierno Yolanda Díaz solo faltaba la
decisión de podemos socio de coalición
del gobierno actual y esta llegó cuando
faltaban 10 horas para que cerrara el
plazo de inscripción de coaliciones para
concurrir a los comicios un plazo que
termina a la medianoche de hoy según Su
secretaria general y actual ministra de
derechos sociales y oneve Larra su firma
está garantizada Pero existe aún el
obstáculo de la inclusión o no en las
listas electorales de la ministra de
igualdad Irene Montero La número dos del
partido su presencia es polémica y algo
incómoda para la izquierda en gran parte
por ser la impulsora de la conocida como
ley del solo siesi que desencadenó en la
rebaja de más de 1100 condenas de
agresores sexuales y la excarcelación de
más de un
esta Unión de la izquierda es clave para
aumentar las opciones de poder alcanzar
mejores resultados en las elecciones
generales que se avecinan y poder llegar
así a un acuerdo de coalición con el
partido socialista del presidente del
gobierno Pedro Sánchez tras el desplome
de votos que sufrió todo el sector
progresista en España en las regionales
y municipales de mayo todas las
encuestas confirman que una concurrencia
por separado de la izquierda aseguraría
que la derecha gobierne Durante los
próximos cuatro años